how's it go branches back Wow today
we're gonna explore the wonderful world
of switch genitalia I asked it was on
Twitter who should be gender bender and
first Justin was Shane teasing Shane
Dawson needs to be a woman she nuttin
needs to be a woman
so it's Shauna yeah must be Shauna
Shauna Shauna Dawson what's annoying
name I ever made up Shauna Shauna Asin
well a little thing yeah yes
let's uh make those lips pop damn girl
oh ye see they already have a very lush
and Rouge color but then let's give them
a very even more decided I think that
was English summer Shane Dawson Shane
Dawson Shinda son Shane Dawson get real
a disgusting pores yucky yucky yucky oh
man well I'm getting turned on so that
means we're doing it right oh ye so what
else does girl have eyeliner eyeliner
let's make sure it's on point that's
what everyone [ __ ] comments when I do
eyeliner on point
well I shadow on point Wow sorry I have
a problem
should we give her longer hair maybe
really be some kind of YouTube
scholarships for people who do great
ideas like I do oh ah
you are so beautiful and wise shenana
huh
what's that her name if I saw a girl
with this luscious hair I would like her
yeah tell me what condition are you
using right now or else [ __ ] stab you
there we go
Shane Jason transformed into Shanna
Dawson Shana shut us I don't know but it
looks fabulous
hi Shane is so natural and beautiful oh
my god my ice burn this very mixture of
comments here next up we have G
enumerables she already dresses up as a
man a lot doesn't she
all right well let's let's try and
recreate this look so Jenna and Jane
James gonna be difficult as [ __ ] cuz she
has hair everywhere nailed it
alright let's get it rid of the makeup
huh
looks great men obviously don't have
eyelashes so this is get rid of those
kind of terrifying but men a real man is
terrifying like me yep it's looking like
a man already oh my god it taught it
looks like a man I am NOT giving myself
enough credit I am a [ __ ] I should
just be a plastic surgeon so we'll just
have a first implant as I like to call
it all right there there there there we
have it
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's good this
gave me hemorrhoids KS KS that would be
kind of funny to see first get rid of
those muscles
shoosh go away muscles no one like you
go away there you go very nice see now
they're the size of my arms this is
great yeah well I this looks good so far
name that v-neck damn it's coming to the
flow official hahaha nice yes oh my god
that looks so [ __ ] good I don't think
I applied this much Photoshop to anyone
and they still look like a man I don't
know how you pull it off
damn girl that actually looks real what
the [ __ ]
see I don't know how he does it it still
looks like a man it's still alright we
need to fix that face okay so this eyes
way cuter than the other eyes so let's
just do an eye implant like I don't
understand
no matter what I do it still looks like
a man
all right you know what so cute so cute
I bet he'll love this I bet I bet
why does chaos I actually looked like a
good-looking woman what the [ __ ] are you
serious okay we have linked from good
mythical morning ah yes oh [ __ ] I mean
they would probably date each other if
um it they yeah um disgusting stubble
disgusting filthy the eyeliner is indeed
on point yeah work it link ah yeah work
it girl looking good for like link looks
like a strong woman who knows what she
wants I like that I like that in a girl
thing credit is a little jealous
okay now we're really talking just do
this quick there we go beautiful I ship
them so much now what is their ship name
rink wreck for after boom bada bing bada
boom bada boom link or so sexy
can't handle ah link is very sexy I do
agree
damn they should call him Zelda now wow
if you want more of these shitty videos
hit that like button and let me know and
as always thanks for watching Bros throw
some gross I mean that looks pretty
natural it's all about looking natural
natural let's get a little rid of that
stubble
yah-tchi yah-tchi yah-tchi disgusting